hello everyone welcome to this program
uh we're gonna change things a little
bit here so that everyone can uh
uh see the screen uh what we'll do today
is we'll
give you an overview of the program i
will pass this on to
sparsh
momentarily but
to give you an introduction
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
is a program designed to introduce you
to the ways that bioinformatics is used
in the study for infectious diseases
coming from different types of pathogens
and what we'll do is we'll introduce you
to
curated
examples
of how you can analyze data where to
find such data and how to make
conclusions
okay so uh what i'll do in my part of
the presentation
is i will review some of the
introductory material about the program
then i will pass it on to uh dr raghav
vendren who is going to review some of
the practical things of how you can get
started with some of the types of data
that is usually used
for
these kinds of studies
so bioinformatics for infectious
diseases is a program that is designed
for biologists clinicians students that
are interested in virology microbiology
and immunology
that would like to learn how to apply
bioinformatics to different types of big
data for research and applications about
infectious diseases to design novel
diagnostic approaches
to understand how antiviral and
antimicrobial drugs are being designed
how vaccines are relying on data and
bioinformatics to
address
new and maybe potentially in the future
upcoming disease outbreaks um and also
how to understand what are some of the
important challenges and questions that
remain to be answered and how
bioinformatics can help us address those
as well
so what i'll do is i'll first explain
how some of the questions
about infectious diseases are related to
bioinformatics
you know
if we can think about this program as
just a series of questions that one can
ask and use bioinformatics to find
potential answers
one question might be
what is a pathogen
what differentiates pathogens from
non-pathogens what differentiates for
example bacteria that coexist together
with humans plants and other hosts
from those that cause disease
how can that help us
understand the evolution or the
conditions of competition that cause
these
microorganisms to evolve
share recipes kind of record what works
and how to adapt what they the tools
that they have to overcome different
types of challenges
another question can be
where do diseases come from how come is
it that some diseases persist
and some diseases have these outbreaks
that are acute that have a beginning
that have an end
where do they come from
how do we understand the origins of
diseases like coronavirus or ebola or
other diseases that cause these endemic
or pandemic outbreaks
how can we understand this in the
context of interaction between different
hosts for example different species
humans their pets
the different cattle that we grow
how can that be a source of novel
pathogens
what is the actual disease that they
cause right how can we describe
the reaction of the host to the pathogen
as a condition that we can diagnose so
what makes that as a
disease and we can think of all of these
microorganisms as essentially parasites
that
leverage some of the resources that the
hosts have accumulated
leverage their mechanisms of production
of vital proteins to be able to
replicate themselves
and how they as a result
of hijacking some of these resources can
also cause toxicity and disruption of
the host function
we'll also talk about how diseases
spread because what characterizes an
infectious disease or a communicable
disease and sets it apart from other
types of diseases which are commonly
known as chronic diseases like cancer
for example or hypertension
is the fact that they're caused by
pathogen and that pathogen
is a
transmittable pathogen you can actually
share it between individuals and so when
we think of that transmission and the
pattern of transmission we can also use
bioinformatics to understand the
population scale
how does the population react to a
disease
for example herd immunity
or how does the population
become susceptible for example having
similar characteristics within a
particular group or a population how can
that make them more susceptible to
particular types of diseases
and we'll also talk about the balance of
replication and how
while a pathogen causes acute disease
oftentimes
one of its objectives is to continue and
replicate and find a balance where it
can continue to replicate and spread
between many individuals causing them to
potentially have mild condition
that does not prevent it from continuing
to replicate
then we'll talk about how to treat or
prevent disease and we'll talk about how
novel advances
are examples of bioinformatics in part
because
understanding the particular situations
where vaccines can be more adapted to
the specifics of the pathogen
and maybe novel antivirals could be
designed based on our understanding of
the interaction between the host and the
pathogen can lead to
novel ways to treat disease but we'll
also talk about how early diagnostics or
understanding specifically what pathogen
and what strain of a pathogen or maybe a
variant of a pathogen is causing a
disease is critical
for the future of these kinds of
interventions because as we will see in
the last portion what remains to be done
we'll see how
the same principles of evolution can
help us understand how the diseases that
are caused by pathogens
are only
preventable if we can develop systems of
early detection and understanding of the
evolution that they undergo because we
can identify precise variants and we can
treat that precise variant but we don't
always know how to anticipate novel
variants and to anticipate novel
variants and design therapeutics that
can potentially
co-evolve with these pathogens
there are new strategies and novel
understanding about how these types of
discoveries can really help us
anticipate and prevent future outbreaks
so in the context of this particular
online program what we have prepared on
our side are a number of examples or
let's call them case studies
case studies where we can take curated
data sets
and start designing bioinformatics
projects where we have a question we
have a data set and then we have a path
to answer that question from that data
set or methods of analysis of data that
could inform some of our understanding
of the answers to these questions
so what are some of these case studies
and data sets
one of them is going to be about the
ebola outbreak in 2014 to 2016.
now what's
interesting about this outbreak is that
it is one of the first examples
where large-scale
genomic sequencing was employed
almost in real time to track an epidemic
to understand how the epidemic is
spreading in a particular
region
and then use this understanding to
design a vaccine in an antiviral drug
another example that we're going to look
at
is going to speak about
the spread of covet 19. and when we
think about covet 19 we obviously hear
so much about it in the news um but what
is exceptionally um
i think
kind of for bioinformaticians is
interesting in this pandemic
specifically is that the amount of data
and the detail of data
is now
very rich and and very
precise uh being updated almost in real
time
from many different regions so really
the scale of the data collection here is
unheard of in any other kind of disease
not only that this particular pandemic
has popularized some of the terms that
we rely on as bioinformaticians to
understand how
genomes of particular pathogens
or how molecular
biology and and kind of the background
of how these pathogens cause disease are
really becoming understood by even the
general public so today everyone
understands what a variant or a mutation
is everyone appreciates the ability to
study some genomic pattern and try to
make inference that has a practical
application we don't have to explain the
need to
understand and maybe
sequence some of these pathogens because
now everyone is
in tune with this scientific endeavor to
try to really understand how this
pathogen is evolving right we don't need
to explain that it is evolving right
everybody knows that so really we're
going to take a look at some of those
data sets in this as well
another example that we will look at is
the development of vaccines to address
the
kind of chronic
or endemic
plasmodium falciparum
spread in africa and in south asia
we'll take a look at how
genomic surveillance and understanding
of both
resistance to some of the known drugs
that are used to treat plasmodium as
well as the efforts to design an
effective vaccine
that turns out to be a non-trivial
effort that requires a deep
understanding of genomic variability
across different regions and the
understanding of how that genomic
variability can be
used or leveraged to really find an
effective way to interfere
we'll also look at how
uh viruses are not only um the result of
these kinds of acute outbreaks of
infectious diseases but we'll also see
how there's a greater appreciation of
the role that viruses play in other
types of diseases for example in
neurodegenerative diseases like multiple
sclerosis
where
maybe
an exciting idea resulting from this
observation is that if we treat the
virus if we find a way to treat the
virus the viral infection we don't have
to deal with the symptoms with the
consequences that are the outcome of
this persistent infection leading to
these long-term deterioration of
the cognitive function
we'll also take a look at how these
types of observations are relevant in
diseases like cancer
where abstain virus and others have
been found to play a major role in the
onset and maybe uh development of these
cancers so i think really
infectious diseases uh now is going from
some of these uh prominent case studies
that we're going to take a look at like
ebola malaria and kovid and even extend
to some of the
non-typically considered as infectious
diseases but
chronic diseases that potentially have a
connection to viral pathogens and others
we'll also look at some of the
challenges that still remain to be
addressed
even though
we think of treatments like antibiotics
for example
as an established way to treat disease
that have been very successful over the
past several decades
these kinds of interventions are new
our ability to design vaccines and adapt
them to particular pathogens is
something that happened in the past
maybe decade our ability to
leverage the antibiotics to treat these
bacterial diseases is also just a few
decades old
and as a result of widespread use of
these
types of interventions we're also seeing
the reverse reaction right where we are
seeing how these types of interventions
can become weaker over time
as a result of evolution and adaptation
we see emergence of
resistance and drug resistant
tuberculosis for example is a major risk
we can see
novel pathogens bacterial pathogens that
are emerging in hospitals that are not
possible to treat with antibiotics we're
also seeing novel variants of these
viral diseases that also do not respond
well to vaccines that were designed so
really these are some of the challenges
that continue to
emerge
in these kinds of effective ways to
leverage bioinformatics and we'll talk
about where we can find some data sets
and what are some of the methods of
analysis that we can leverage to try and
answer some of these questions and
challenges
now where can you find some of these
we have designed a portal where our team
has curated project examples
and
tutorials that you can leverage
as an independent learner as someone who
just wants to obtain some bioinformatics
skills or as someone that would like to
apply some of the bioinformatics skills
to a particular research question
and so those are some of the things that
you will find on the portal and i will
explain today how you can leverage this
portal more effectively in the context
of this online training portal that is
going to provide you with live sessions
as well as some of these online
resources that you can leverage to
really master some of these skills and
practice them on particular examples
so to talk about this i'll speak about
where you can find a particular resource
that you might be interested in how you
can find different categories or even
collection of different courses and
we'll see how to get started
now beyond this i want to mention that
what you will hear in this program is
going to be based on tutorials that were
prepared in collaboration with a number
of experts in this domain so really what
we did is we worked with the number of
researchers that are actively
investigating
um all of these topics from the
perspective of pure bioinformatics or an
algorithmic perspective how to design
methods to analyze such data effectively
we've worked with researchers that
specialize in some of these pathogens
and have been performing research in the
area of malaria or coronaviruses for a
long time and also people that apply the
bioinformatics to connect the biological
questions with the specific data sets
that are available and are being
extended and
populated with these new
viral and bacterial genomes or even
parasite genomes in the case of malaria
to try and answer these questions
comprehensively so we'll
leverage their expertise and we'll
present to you some of the findings and
and questions and solutions that they
have identified
so what is this program all about this
program bioinformatics for infectious
diseases is going to help you understand
pathogens and the diseases that they
cause
where they come from
what are the processes that cause
the different types of changes in their
genomes that we can observe
how can they cause infection and how can
that infection cause disease
we'll also talk about the specific ways
to analyze such data a lot of this data
is going to be focused on the
understanding of genomic variability and
how to identify specific genomic
variants and characterize them in terms
of their impact on the pathogen itself
on the interaction between the pathogen
and the host and potentially on the
intervention in that interaction
we'll also talk about how you can apply
some of these principles to study a
variety of different curated data sets
identify the questions that are
important for these data sets and then
use the data sets and the methods that
we described to find answers to these
important questions and again you will
have access to some resources that will
make your life easier if you're just
getting started but also for those of
you that are already more advanced we
will help you
connect the dots and really apply these
methods in an effective way
now the program is going to help you by
leveraging two
primary resources that i want to
introduce briefly before we begin
the first of
them is going to be our big data
analysis platform some of these data
sets are going to be exceptionally large
we're going to leverage hundreds if not
thousands of genomes at a specific time
we're going to look at complex data like
rna sequencing even single cell rna
sequencing and so to facilitate some of
the educational aspects of our
interaction we're going to rely on this
platform that i'm going to demonstrate
in just a few moments
the other part is of course our omics
logic portal that i already briefly
mentioned but i want to highlight the
significance of this online resource
because it provides a collection of
elements that are going to be useful as
you
start in this particular program and
continue after that so that you can
understand the high level overview in a
short program like we have today but
then continue by leveraging some of the
specific technical tutorials to really
expand and practice and master these
skills so that you are independent and
confident in the way that you apply them
so before we begin what i would like
everyone to do is to log in to this
portal so let's go to
learn.omixlogic.com
this is a portal where you can register
for free so anyone even if you're not
going to participate in this particular
program you can register
and i'll i'm putting this link here so
that all of you who have not registered
as of now can take a moment to register
now i'm going to demonstrate and please
follow along if you have not registered
already
so i'm going to log out
the first thing that you will see right
here in the menu
is this login screen
okay so if you press on the login
you can either log in with your email
and password
you can create an account again this is
the free account you put in your name
email and think of a password
or you can also use different types of
social media plugins so after you have
created that
i'm just going to use my own password to
log
login
and the first thing that you will see if
you are registering for the first time
is actually the pricing page but if you
go from the pricing page
you should see right here on the very
top
your email address and so that's what we
want to do is we want to click on this
email address right here
so this email address is your
profile
okay so please let me know once you have
your profile in front of you i'm going
to walk you through some of the things
that you're going to be seeing so just
let me know in the chat by saying yes
putting number one or something in the
chat so that i know that you're with me
on your profile
[Music]
all right excellent thank you brian
helene
again i'm going to give another 30
seconds for those of you that are still
creating your profile please let me know
once you're done
all right thank you priyanka sarah
excellent okay
anna
all right
so
this profile is really designed to kind
of connect all of the different
resources
uh naveen the the creation of the
profile itself is free so really there's
no shouldn't be any worry about cost
right now right the profile is free
you'll have access to a lot of free
resources if you have questions about
pricing uh later on uh please reach out
to our marketing team but right now i'm
just showing you a free resource that
you can already leverage from day one so
in this profile you'll see how the
different resources are connected
to your learning journey
and we're
kind of emphasizing this section because
really this is where you can track your
progress you can go back to where you
were to pick up where you started you
can always find your certification here
etc so all of this material is going to
be here
what is the expectation of this
particular program
this particular program will help you
identify the specific topics that you
need to master
try to apply them to different projects
and then use the annotation of our
tracking of your progress to earn a
certificate and so this certificate is
going to be the validation of your
kind of understanding of bioinformatics
in infectious diseases number one
but number two it will also provide you
with an opportunity to develop an
independent research uh project so one
of our
primary objectives in these kinds of
training programs is to support
research that is coming
from a bioinformatics perspective
how to apply bioinformatics to research
that is what we're really going to
address in this training program now
this training program will have a
dedicated program page
on that page you will find all of the
sessions that will be recorded
you will also find a schedule of how to
uh go to the right kind of a topic at
the right time
and
how to connect to the live sessions that
we have
today
like
now beyond that you will also find all
of the resources now we understand that
many of you are coming from different
backgrounds you might be already an
expert in bioinformatics and you would
like to understand how specifically
bioinformatics applies to infectious
diseases or you might be a complete
novice and you really don't know a lot
of the topics that we are discussing
maybe you're not familiar with the
terminology for example so that's why we
include in this particular program also
the introductory coursework like bytes
and molecules introduction to
bioinformatics and others where you can
start with the very basics and develop
your
kind of understanding of the different
terms that you will find useful as we go
through the different case studies
as i mentioned we will have some live
sessions like today but we will also
have recorded sessions and so you will
find those in the schedule and you will
finally be able to interact with our
community by asking them questions
about the specific topics that we are
discussing and getting maybe technical
answers to overcome your challenges so
if you ever get stuck and if you ever
have maybe a frustration like always
happens in these online courses i don't
understand i i can't do what you know
i'm being told to do you can always
reach out to us so our team is going to
be there to support your journey
and you're going to be able to
then go through uh the specific
tutorials that we recommend to learn
about them
now if you don't see any courses that is
because you are likely just signing up
so if you go to this page the course tab
has the courses that you've already
started okay if you want to find a
course you have to go to the top menu
and this is our library of resources and
find the relevant course for example if
i would like to learn about covid
i will find stars go to genomics
as an introductory project right here so
once you start this and you start by
clicking on the lesson and now you've
started this project you can learn
through and then click on next and
eventually that will appear on your
profile as well so christine hopefully
that answers your question right there
okay so
finally before we go on i want to
recommend
you to connect to our community as well
so what this program represents is a
community effort not only are we going
to have these kinds of sessions and
interact with you try to help you try to
explain some of these topics in an
accessible approachable way and really
distill these complex topics to some
simple exercises that anyone can perform
we're also there to connect a community
of learners to opportunities and those
opportunities might be professional
opportunities to develop your career in
bioinformatics also opportunities to
connect with potential research
collaborators so we're going to
introduce you to some of those groups
and today i'm just going to share here
in the chat two of our groups that you
can connect to one of them is on
linkedin and another one is on facebook
for those of you that are on either one
of those platforms we welcome you to
connect with us personally but also to
connect with the broader community that
we serve we have over i think 1500
people on linkedin over 10 000 people on
facebook so
you can really
leverage this community to not only
learn about bioinformatics for
infectious diseases but then also to
continue and apply bioinformatics to
other domains and to advance your career
or find opportunities for research
so today's session
is going to be dedicated to next
generation sequencing
one of the technologies that has really
advanced our understanding and ability
to treat and diagnose diseases like
infectious diseases is our ability to
sequence genomes and transcriptomes and
understand what's going on at the
molecular level
so when we think about next generation
sequencing and the way it has become
popular and maybe widely used as a
technique
this has happened in the course of the
past couple of decades and today with
decreasing cost of sequencing it is
being used in remote uh areas where some
of these diseases are originating where
some of these diseases are being changed
and transformed but also in most uh kind
of technologically advanced places it is
becoming a more and more reliable and uh
useful technology to understand
infectious diseases
so to learn more about this technique i
am going to invite dr raghav to speak
about how next generation sequencing
works
what it contains what kind of
information it contains and how you can
potentially start learning to use it to
actually apply it
in the context of infectious diseases
so raghav
yeah hello everybody let me find ways to
share my screen
okay
are you [ __ ] on your screen
yeah yeah it's
my powerpoint is not responding just a
second i quit and rejoin
okay while he's rejoining
i will uh get started with that
presentation
and then once he's back um he will take
over so let me
share my screen again
one second
okay
so
one of the things that we know today
is that
the viruses
bacteria
parasites and other pathogens
surround us and coexist with
hosts
like humans
and one of the things that we would like
to understand is what differentiates
specific pathogenic microorganisms from
non-pathogenic microorganisms
so this leads us to this concept of a
viral
viruses are obviously some of the most
clearly understood pathogens
they actually are not characterized as
living microorganisms but they only live
in a host they can only replicate within
a host
and when we think about viruses we can
think about the virum or the collection
of all the viruses that are present in a
specific environmental sample
environment here can be the human gut
the human lungs it could be the water
that we drink
or it could be anything around us and so
viron
or micro
biome are these collections of
microorganisms that we can sample and
clearly identify
now within the birom or the microbiome
we can start characterizing the specific
individual
microorganisms
and one of the important things is that
because of the next generation
sequencing technology we now have a
variety of viruses
bacteria parasites that are
characterized at the genomic level
now the genomic revolution that
originally started because we wanted to
understand the human genome has in
parallel led to an explosion of the
number of viral bacterial and
other types of microorganisms genomes
being sequenced and studied
and here you can see just a glimpse of
how much information is available and
you can see here that the most studied
viruses for example are the viruses that
are commonly found to be pathogenic to
humans
now obviously we can kind of understand
the logic behind this for example just
if we look
at the scale at which covid19 is being
sequenced we can see that the major
outbreaks of
infectious diseases like stars one ebola
zika mers and now covet 19 have been the
spikes in sequencing why do we want to
sequence these genomes and why
particularly do we want to sequence
pathogenic genomes
well one of the things that we want to
try to understand when we're sequencing
these pathogens is the specific recipe
that these pathogens employ
to be effective at what they do which is
to replicate
evade our immune response and ultimately
adapt to the different types of
responses that typically work but in
their cases they're not working to
overcome and continue and spread within
the population
so these pathogens
that we are going to study in this
program are going to be studied using
next generation sequencing to understand
their genome and then we're going to
apply the same technology to understand
the response how does the human
immune system respond to these different
pathogens how does it vary across
different types of disease
manifestations and how can we
characterize those interventions that we
can design
based on this interaction that we
understand because of next generation
sequencing data so really the critical
thing here is to understand this
technology
how exactly does it work but also how
can we analyze such data and how can we
translate the analysis to biological
insights that are actionable that are
informative and actionable
so what is
next generation sequencing and now we're
going to start with thinking about next
generation sequencing in the context of
pathogens how can we use next-generation
sequencing to understand the genomic
structure of viruses and bacteria and
how can we learn to identify important
variation that we think leads to their
their manifestation of disease how do
they cause disease
metagenomic and viral sequencing can be
of several different types
specifically we can look at targeted
regions that we already know for example
ribosomal rna
is one way to look at only bacteria
because bacteria have ribosomal rna that
is different in structure from
for example human ribosomal rna and so
that's how we can amplify a particular
type of a sequence to identify only
bacterial dna or rna
another example for targeted sequencing
is what we hear for starscope 2 when we
only want to look at
for example variants of concern that
affect the
spike protein and so then we know how to
amplify only the region that contains
the sequence for the spike protein so we
can sequence particular regions by
amplifying them and that's called
targeted sequencing
another type of sequencing is total dna
or rna when we're not looking for any
particular region but we're saying let
us just extract all of the genomic
material from a particular sample and
sequence everything
and then finally you can see here
amplicon environmental in the same
example when we have a particular type
so one type targeted would be let's
target the spike gene another one let's
do a type of a sequence and we'll
understand the composition of a
particular sample
now these are very different approaches
but they rely on the same technology
so to help you learn in detail we
recommend these three particular
articles that you can read through on
your own and we'll share at the end of
today's session the links to these
articles that will help you understand
how these types of sequencing approaches
are helping us understand uh the
presence and and characteristics of
different pathogens
now let's talk about sequencing
specifically in the context of
viral uh communities
uh in bacterial communities right so
microorganisms again pathogens so a lot
of times one of the challenges with
metagenomics when we have an
environmental sample that contains a lot
of different present organisms we would
like to understand how all of these
different organisms are characterizing
the environmental sample
now
in bacterial examples there's always a
challenge because with bacteria we don't
we are not able to
isolate and grow individual bacteria
only one percent of bacterial
isolates could be grown in the lab so
one of the questions would be well how
do these bacterial
communities exist in real life in in the
real world and to do that we have the
approach of metagenomics with viruses
it's the same thing
not only do we have viruses interacting
with other viruses these viruses also
interact with other bacteria in fact the
majority of viruses are
bacterial
viruses viruses that only infect
bacterial cells
so when we think of a particular virus
that is causing a disease we would like
to understand the community or the
environment where that virus came from
and in many cases we would like to
characterize that particular one
pathogen
how that pathogen is different from the
others that it lives together with or
that interacts with others
like them
and then understand how the sequence of
that particular virus can be in a piece
of information that we can use how can
we use that piece of information in
viral outbreaks we would like to take a
clinical specimen for example a human
blood sample and we would like to find
all of the viruses that are present in
that clinical sample for example if we
have a
temperature if we have
vomiting if we have cough right we want
to understand what is the particular
pathogen causing the manifestation of
that disease and to do that what we can
do is we can sequence everything that is
in that sample that includes the host
genome and maybe genomic material
as well as anything else that is present
there
sometimes we already know
so if we have a particular
virus that we think is causing the
infection right we can design a primer
specifically amplify those regions that
we know should be present based on the
virus strain that we think is present in
this particular patient and then try to
understand is that the same strain that
we expect it to be or is it somehow
different from the reference that we
have now in many cases we also have
multiple causes of a condition right and
so what's important at the first stage
is to try to understand what all is
present in a particular sample and we
can do that because
we have different types of data where we
can store the resources about potential
organisms that we can find for example
we have a database of microorganisms or
a database of viral genomes and we can
now compare and contrast what we find in
a sample with what we will find in a
particular sample that we have
or or what is known to be in a database
now to understand how these different
techniques are going to be useful in the
context of next generation sequencing we
have to understand the types of files
that are used to store and retrieve such
information
so i think rack raghav now is ready to
take over i think he's uh got his
presentation working as well right raga
yes yes yes i got it uh sorry for the
interruption but i just had to restart
my system something yeah my zoom and ppt
never spoke with each other okay
please go ahead
yes thank you very much
so yeah
just confirm me that uh
stop my video yes we can see
yeah you can you can see my screen yes
okay that's fine that's great but i
think you cannot see my
video because
yeah just a second let me
okay now we can
yes great
okay let's
so we already learned about
why and how ngs is going to help us
characterize different whole genome
sequences of these infectious diseases
and why in the context of why it is
going to be very important in ah perform
an analysis like next in sequencing
analysis sequencing methodology
to uh identify or to sequence the whole
genome of uh pathogens so let's let's go
through some of the important concepts
or some of the important outlines of how
negative sequencing data is generated
and what are the different file forms uh
that are
associated with nextion sequencing data
and how we can uh use the talbot by info
platform to run a
pipeline for this sequencing data
analysis so yeah
so this is very important because it is
related to our ability to compare the
dna code of any given ah
system in this case like a virus or or
even a bacteria to a reference sequence
of the same system right um if you if
you want to identify a new strain in the
uh that is circulating around in during
this pandemic then we sequence this um
sequencer data from the samples uh that
have a different behavioral
characteristics of the different
virulence and then compare it with the
reference genome that is uh
characterized in the
database so let's uh this is these these
analyses and these different uh these
these different technologies are made
possible through the advances that takes
millions and millions of cheaply
generated short read sequences and align
them to a reference
that will help us extract meaningful
insights
in the biological system that we are
considering so this sequencing
technology actually helps us to explore
genetic variations like um
like never before like we can
use different types of the sequencing to
address the particular
specific need that we want to
address like in the case of a targeted
sequencing panel we will have high
coverage but we are going to target only
40 to 400 genes in the in terms of
human genome or if you want to target
specific genes in terms of viral genome
we don't have to do that because viral
sequences our genomes are tend to be
very short in length and people go for
whole genome sequencing of pathogens
that is like virus etc but in terms of a
human genome then we can use uh targeted
sequencing or whole exome sequencing or
whole genome sequencing to ah tailor the
kind of sequencing
experiment that we want to perform on
the samples that we have so these three
different sequencing efforts they have
um their own advantages and
disadvantages so some of the advantages
that would
categorize or differentiate them is the
is and questions are there is a
biological implications that they can be
used to perform like whole genome
sequencing can be helped
even though in spite of low coverage can
be performed on a large number of
samples to identify
specifically
those variants which are very rare and
their association with the disease state
or association with the phenotypical
history that the uh um samples are uh
actually uh
representing or depicting whole exome
sequencing will give you a trans
transcriptomic snapshot of the
of the system at the particular time so
that is going to give you the expression
profiles or
give you the expression quantification
of all the
coding
coding genes uh at that particular
snapshot and targeted sequencing panel
will help you specifically target little
portions of the genome so that we can
perform or we can understand their
variation with respect to the reference
sequence at a very high coverage so that
very rare mutations and very rare
variants can be analyzed and identified
and then addressed
addressed with with lot of confidence
so
so how this is done so this is done by
um
yeah this is done by uh
by first um collecting or first sharing
the genomic dna into uh into multiple
small
fragments of 200 to 300 base pairs and
then we attach the adapters to these uh
to these fragments and then these
adapters are then
attached adapters are then applied to
the flow cell where they are
then
amplified using a bridge pcr uh
technique and then uh these amplified
sheared fragments are then sequenced by
the sequencer machine uh in um
and these sequenced
fragments are called as sequence calls
uh depending upon their uh specific
nucleotide in a t g or c so
so the the ngs sequencing machine or
sequencing technology basically converts
or basically takes the
biological sample and converts them into
a digital sequencing data that it gives
us an output in the form of fast q files
so these outputs that we have
from the ngs sequencing uh
machines and ngo sequencing technology
or high throughput sequencing technology
are given us in
fast queue format so first key format is
yes a fast queue format
and we we also there is also another
format that is
related to first q and is very
very important in the
analysis pipeline of this nga sequencing
sequencing data uh that is faster format
and gta format let's go through first
queue format first and then let's come
back to the faster format uh
so the first queue format the fascio
file reads like this so the fascio file
has a starting header which contains the
important information such as the
read name their length and different
sample characteristics and all the
different characteristics that one can
associate with this particular read and
the next line
describes the next line actually depicts
the actual calls of the nucleotide
themselves so this these are the actual
actual reads actual
sequences that are sequenced by the ngs
sequencers and then we have a separator
that is usually that usually separates
these uh base calls from the quality
scores that is associated with each one
of these base calls and that separator
is a is a plus sign and sometimes this
this separated line is also populated
with the same information that one finds
with the header so and then after the
separator we get the quality scores that
is associated with each and every one of
these base calls in ascii format so
these each and every one of these
characters represent or they actually
tell us how confident we are or how
confident the uh sequencing um
technology is about uh the placement is
about the call of this particular um
a particular base at that at that
specific position this is used right
throughout our downstream analysis where
first this is used to filter uh those
reads which are of low quality and then
even until the end where we can
associate our
variant uh through the
variant identified variance
with the
quality score that
that it is attached to or that it is
called with so let's go back to the
fasta file format this is another file
format which is used usually used in the
ngs sequencing fibrin where when when we
have to map the first queue files or the
region the first q files form it to the
reference genome so first file format is
usually reserved for the reference
genome where this file format is a very
simple text based file format where the
first line star usually starts with the
greater than symbol and then what
follows is the header for this first q
file fasta file uh
for the whole genome sequence of this
file so this header will have important
information like accession id the name
of the species and
in addition to that they can also have
the strain names or isolate names or or
the type of
technology used to sequence this data
and etc etc and ah and after that what
follows is the actual whole genome
sequence of this uh
whole genome sequence of this particular
species for example in this uh it's a
spot of terra and in this case it's a
rabies virus so this is the this is the
genome sequence right from the first
nucleotide to the last nucleotide given
in a you know one single line or one
single uh
entry so this doesn't actually describe
uh
in terms of eukaryotic genome which
portions of this
genome sequence are coding sequences or
which portions of this genome sequence
are non-coding sequences or which uh
which portions are exon x1 or intron in
terms of within gene so that information
is actually loaded or that information
is actually supplied with a gtf file so
the or gff file um which tells us at
what position can we find the
coding region at what position can we
find the um exons and what position can
we find the non-coding regions of this
in this fasta file for the reference uh
sequence so
these three are absolutely essential for
performing a ah
performing a ngs
pipeline analysis of uh
sequence to data
and what happens is the first q files
which represents the reads that are
that are sequenced they are mapped on to
the reference uh genome which in the
faster files are here you can see the
reference genome and then these are the
reads that are mapped on to this
particular position specific position
based on the sequence alignment or
decentralized sequence identity on this
one so here
let's yeah this is a detailed view of
how this is performed and how this can
be visualized so uh
in this in this representation here this
this gray bar
represents the genome sequence
and this um
big gray bar represents the gene and
these ones are non-coding areas
non-coding regions and these blue bars
and uh red bars represents the the red
bars and blue bars represents the um
forward stand and reverse strand
respectively and they can be mapped like
this onto the reference genome and then
identify and then their specific
and the variation that is present in
these first q files with respect to the
reference genome can be identified and
then they can be characterized so to
visualize the whole mapping and the
whole
and the processes of this mapping and
output they can be visualized using uh
some visualizing tool like jbrowser or
igd and these are the standard
visualizing tools that one uses to
visualize this uh mapping algorithm
uh
so here
so here we have the reference sequence
that is mentioned in this one and then
what follows is the consensus or what
follows is a coverage of this uh
of this map
reads so we have we do not have a
uniform coverage because of the
technology it is not uniformly uh red or
uniformly sequenced at all the level so
these chunks of small fast q files these
some chunks of small reads they get
mapped to the genome and based on their
based on the
coverage like here we have really high
coverage where we have many very many
reads that are aligned at this position
so we see that the coverage is really
high but here the coverage is very very
low or very shallow because we do not
have a lot of reads at this particular
position so these
this can be visualized and and
in addition to visualizing the
mapping
of these uh regions of the genome we can
also
identify specific uh mutation at these
parts
positions which can also be
visualized
in this one so let me quickly go to a
target bio info platform and show you
how to run a simple visualization
pipeline for uh um
for a viral genome so let's take it
forward there and
and then come back again to here
share screen
can you see my
screen i think you can see my screen
let's yeah let's go to server.tbioinfo
and then here if you uh go to genomics
analysis and then and then under
mutation variant and parallel analysis
of mutation variant data your drop down
so we have prepared some uh demo
pipelines and demo um
yeah demo pipelines which will give you
the feeling of running these analysis or
running this pipeline building up this
pipeline for this sequence analysis
and then
you can access the output files and you
can
perform the similar analysis that we are
performing in the
using the output file you can visualize
you can
perform
a downstream analysis with the output
file and you can learn what these files
can be what these uh
pipelines can be built for and how the
output can be
leveraged to perform multiple analysis
so let's yeah let's build this start
here usually the input files are
uploaded because it is a demo pipeline
and we
then after starting we map the reads
onto the
genome using bow tie two algorithm
and we go there and then after this we
uh complete this pipeline with
visualization
tool and we end it in the pipeline and
after you end the pipeline you get
access to download all the pipeline
results where we have uh the mapping
statistics of these
reads mapped onto the genome and we have
the
sequence alignment map or uh sam file
which is the
alignment file uh mapped file in in
in a yeah in a uh
some format this is also this can also
be given in a binary alignment map file
in binary format and we have the input
fastq files that we have provided for
this mapping or provided for this
analysis and this is the um
yeah i think this is the reference
genome and then let's if under this
table under this section there is a uh
small uh
clickable link called visualization if
you click this logo okay
if you click this visualization usually
uh this should give you a visualization
like this let's
let's strive for some some other format
and
i don't know why this one is not working
okay
so you follow the same process you map
it
onto the reference genome
and you visualize
okay
some issue with this which will be
sorted out later
let's go back to the powerpoint so i can
show you in the powerpoint how you can
visualize this
so this is this is what the
visualization is will look like where
you have lot of
reads attached or
aligned to the reference you know and
this will tell you or this will
characterize the sequence
coverage at that at each and every
position of this reference in this
reference genome file and also it will
also characterize so it will show you
and the variance that you can identify
are the variants that you can observe in
the
sequence
rates that you have so far so let's
let's move forward and
see this is just one one set of analysis
where you can leverage the ng sequencing
technology to
perform sequencing on the sample of your
own but you can also in in in the in the
event of available sequenced data you
can also perform a comparative analysis
which will give you uh
okay a comparative analysis where you
can collect uh different whole genome
sequences from the publicly available uh
repositories like ncbi virus and that
and then you can perform a multiple
sequence alignment and
comparative analysis of these whole
genome sequences of different viral
strains that we we can collect for
example here we can collect all beta
corona virus genomes and that are
characterized by different
different countries from different hosts
and different countries of origin and
different strains and etcetera etcetera
so we can
perform a multiple sequence alignment of
the whole genome of these different
multiple strains of this
sars virus for example and that is going
to help us identify those specific
variants um
are those variants that are specific to
these strains are specific to different
uh um
location of uh
location of isolation iso location that
these
viral samples are
obtained from and this multiple sequence
alignment that we will perform on this
whole genome sequence data will form the
bedrock or will form the basis on which
a phylogenetic reconstruction can be ah
can be uh done or can be performed uh
using the pipeline again and this will
actually give us uh those sequences or
those strains that are closely related
to each other in terms of evolutionary
uh um in terms of evolution of these
viral strains and they are
not closely related or they are far away
in terms of their um
viral evolution so there are multiple
algorithms or the multiple phylogenetic
reconstructive method that is available
in the pipeline to perform such an
analysis and this analysis will help us
identify which sequences or which
strains in this case are close together
and we can relate their variance
to their
grouping by
for example in this case strains or we
can also
i find out whether this
these
different groupings that identified by
the phylogenetic tree
can represent their other phenotypical
characteristics like
different geo locations or different
or different
variants like delta and other omicron
variants etcetera etc that we can
use it for so we can extend this
multiple sequence alignment into
analysis of viral proteins where in
addition to analysis in addition to
identifying variants in the nucleotide
sequences we can identify or we can
extend that to the amino acid sequences
that these genes code for and that will
give us the
mutations or variants or um
that are specific or that are uh that we
can relate to the
viral proteins for example
yeah this uh this can be leveraged to do
that and in viral proteins we will focus
today uh on on the glycoprotein or spike
glycoprotein where one can extend this
mutation and reaction this multiple
sequence alignment two and glycoprotein
for example and uh identify um
differences in the glycoproteins or
surface proteins spike protein
between different strains that will help
us
and that will help us relate to the
virulence or the pathogenicity of this
particular virus
when this virus
recognizes the host cell using this
spike protein or using this glycoprotein
using other uh different proteins that
we that the virus deploys so this uh
this analysis will form the bedrock or
will form the basis of vaccine design as
well so if one identifies from these
multiple sequence alignment
those stretch of sequences that are
common let me go back okay it's taking
so long it's not responding also yeah
yeah for example in this case if one
identifies those such of sequences uh
between different strains that are
common uh in and those such of sequences
that have higher tendency to get a
mutated or higher variance then we can
specifically design our vaccines to
target the common reagents of these
surface proteins so that that becomes
one of the strategies in which these
vaccines are developed and
and that's how these vaccines are
targeted and
and they can uh when targeted and when
these vaccines are
deployed they can
interfere with the ability of these
surface proteins to bind to the host
host cell and then impair their
virulence and then help us in developing
um unnecessary meaning in response to
this particular ones so this is how this
is actually this is how this
coronavirus vaccine is targeted using
one of the targets is a spike protein
and then we can also using similar
analysis identify stretches and identify
those region where the antiviral drugs
can target and these drugs can also be
helped to
bind to those regions of these
of these of different proteins in the
virus or with different proteins that
are specific to the virus and these
proteins are essential for the virus to
survive as it at it as it involves in um
involves in the
involves in the necessary uh viral
propagation of a system and if we can
find a
specific um um
[Music]
inhibitor that will stop or that will uh
um
that will affect or that will impair the
function of these viral protein in
specific then
this can also be leveraged so the the
comparative sequence analysis of whole
genome sequences and then uh extended to
ah
see comparative analysis on the protein
sequences that these genes encode
specifically from different strains of
virus and different
different from these different regions
these viruses are isolated from will
form the bedrock of um such biological
advances that we are getting like the
vaccines and like other interferences
that we can
create to stop the pathogenicity of this
virus so uh we have uh such uh we have
prepared such a project in in this uh
in the omixlogic platform and this will
uh you will have a lot of uh information
and you'll have a detailed uh
lessons on how to perform these analysis
and how to use the robot bioinfor
platform to perform these analysis so
that
related biological
inferences can be um
yeah can be uh implications can be
performed and can be related to the
pathogenicity or to the virulence of
this
virus or different um
infectious
agents so that will conclude my session
today i will
hand it over back to
[Music]
sparsh i think yes brush is going to
take over for me
thank you so much doctor raghovan for
such an insightful session
so let me just screen uh share my screen
uh hi spash um this is mohit um actually
before you start your presentation i
also wanted to show like everyone a
little bit about the next session what
it will be about and also
um we have a wonderful opportunity with
another workshop coming up
on saskof2 uh
variant analysis so i wanted to showcase
that as well so can i do that and then
quickly you can
that's right
thank you
uh is my screen
yes so your screen is visible
all right so the next session uh will be
about um um on friday uh 15 february
february 18th
and uh we will start a little bit early
for this session the first session then
um basically what we are going to do is
to is to understand uh the uh ngs
workflow so before starting the ngs next
generation sequencing workflow usually
what we do is isolate and purify your
nucleic acid and then uh dna extraction
methods also can introduce inhibitors
which can affect the workflow so there
are some other steps that we are going
to discuss that what is being used
before data analysis
so i mean we will also discuss that
different
methods
for virus discovery right like cell
culture inoculation sequence independent
pcrs they have been used and now the
emergence of ngs that has entirely
changed the field of virus discovery so
we discussed that in the first half of
the session so um in the next session we
will be discussing about this technology
illuminate technology so
so raja vermin ketu a clinical genomics
specialist from plymouth life sciences a
company which is focused on illumina
sequencing and is
specializes on
like helping
scientific community with
the instruments and
and the analysis and all of that so uh
doctor so raj javerman will be letting
us know i will be helping us learn about
all of that uh the initial steps so and
it would be followed by another um
session i mean by one of the experts
from premas which will be about finding
ngs data from
public repositories uh so we will be
looking at
once the data is you know prepared and
it is
it is being generated by the machine
how do you go to the next step uh how do
you prepare your data to be submitted
and when it is submitted
and it is on a public portal and it is
on a public repository
how do you understand where it is how do
you find that information relevant to
your project and also like um
getting to that data and how to
interpret that entry so that is uh one
of the challenge that many students
faced so we thought that it would be
nice to have a guest session in this
program where uh experts who are working
on this every day can come and tell you
about these things and so that we can
all on all learn about it
so that's about uh the
two sessions that we have next on on
february 18th but we have a lot of uh
upcoming wonderful opportunities and
exciting sessions coming up in march so
in march we are going to start with a
program uh which is a short workshop for
three days it's about genomic
surveillance of uh
saskof2
variant of concerns
so in this program we will be speaking
about importance of genomic surveillance
for noble emerging variants and
consequences of large scale by
vaccination on its evolution so as we
were discussing that throughout this in
this presentation so in this in this
short workshop we will be doing uh
different kind of activities
so that would be also include that would
also include like generating a report so
if anyone who's working on coronavirus
uh
suscof2 and uh other viruses and if uh
what is the purpose of doing that
analysis so generating and finding that
in a form of a report that actually
helps to understand the analysis in a
very simple way and also to do this at a
genomic level so this program will cons
will be like this short workshop will
cover all those things so let me quickly
take you through the sessions that we
have planned for this for this uh start
workshop starting from first march to
third march so we will start with a
session that would be about you know
ngs uh irtpcr and how to detect uh viral
particles sequencing of genome genomes
and detection of variants
so we will be talking about uh
established protocols like illuminatic
protocol used for full genome sequencing
and pcr primers for variant tracking so
this would be the first introductory
session that is for genomic surveillance
where we will be learning about all the
data collection methods then in the next
session uh we will be learning about
using ngs data to find uh
using one second please
so yeah in the next session we will be
reviewing i will it will be a hands-on
session uh completely so here we will be
learning learn to load uh files from ngs
pipeline into r using custom scripts and
how this is uh and then uh before that
we will be learning how to build a
pipeline and how to unders uh understand
the outputs of these different
algorithms that are used in a workflow
which is a pipeline for genomic analysis
or viral genome analysis
so this will be the second session uh
that will be an hour after the first
session
and after that we will have a con we
will have another introductory session
session on nature of emerging variants
why they are causing concern why what
might be the driving force behind the
observed plates or substrings of this
virus as it continues to spread around
the world so that's the overview and we
in this session we will be learning
about uh from a data perspective so we
will be going to ncbi virus and we will
be looking at different strains and then
we will be doing analysis on the tbinfo
platform where we will be learning about
how they differ and what how they are
emerging and connecting it with
so this is the first session which is
another beginner's day these are these
are the first day plan uh it will be for
three hours or two and a half hour
and a half hours
and the second day which is the day two
um
which is on wednesday second march uh we
will have an uh asynchronous session
which would be not a live session in
this session we will be expecting the
participants who are joining the
workshop and doing it with us to learn
about uh these different resources and
courses that you can already do it in
the infectious disease program as well
but in addition to that there will be
assignments to do some covet cover
related research and analysis so this is
the day two and after that the third day
would be a research level uh uh
meetings we will have research level
uh analysis so in this uh in this
session what we are going to do
is that we are going to learn about
one second there are some chats that we
are getting so in this session we are
going to learn about um the hands-on
analysis
for the logic behind like developing a
workflow so what are the different
variant workflows that we are using and
how these samples that are varying from
like clinical samples to environmental
samples to waste water how they are how
they are being utilized
to do this sort of analysis and how many
uh universities and many pis and a lot
of data is emerging from these sort of
analysis and what is the
next step and how it is going to help us
so all of that will be covered uh in the
introductory session uh session followed
by the research level session that would
be followed by the second session which
would be about the downstream analysis
of genomic data if evolutionary studies
and then biology journey and
origin tracing and reporting so this is
another specialized session uh i mean um
designed for those who are uh going to
who have interest in going in depth into
into the
variation understanding and
understanding how it could impact at a
level of
you know the question research question
so this will be in the next session
followed by that we will be learning how
all of this could be
made into a report that could be uh that
could give us insights about this entire
analysis that we have performed for
variant and how that correlates for
whenever vaccine implications or at as
as a structure structural level how it
reflects so understanding the impact of
the mutation and finding from the heap
of data and like all those
difficulties that make this analysis
really challenging we would want we
would be simplifying that uh throughout
this entire uh workshop and one of the
reasons
what we are doing this is also that we
are launching this as a research support
as a research support so many who are
interested in
analyzing their data we will be able to
help them analyze their data through
this
so this is what i wanted to share and i
would be looking at the questions if
there are any and would be i would
really uh love to help those who have
any queries about this and now i'll pass
it back to sparsh to take this forward
thank you everyone
thank you so much
let me just share my screen
uh dr mohit could you please confirm uh
if my screen is visible or not
yes but your screen is visible and once
you're done please hand it over to dr
agar so he wanted to show the
visualization part it's working now
sure so
i'll do something
thank you
uh so hello everyone uh i'm
hello everyone
i'm sparsh and i'm going to quickly
guide you through with the program page
of bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
so this program is an online one month
mentor guided program and will end on
21st of march
so
i'll just share
the link of this program in the chat box
in just a moment
here's the link
yes so in this program page you will go
through with the program overview
and here is the slabs of all the
interactive sessions which will be there
which will be included in the a one
month mentor guided program till 21st of
march
now
those who haven't enrolled themselves
yet for the program
i am briefly
letting them know about the three level
of subscription
uh
they need to choose from
so the three level of subscription one
of the level of subscription is beginner
level of subscription and the fees for
that level of subscription is dollar 150
and the resources which are include
under that level is online tutorials
project examples cloud pipelines coding
sessions session recordings
live group sessions and certificate for
completion
now moving on to the second level of
subscription that is intermediate level
of subscription and the fees for that is
dollar 250 and the resources which we'll
be providing is online tutorials project
examples cloud pipelines coding session
session recordings live group sessions
plus one-on-one mentor support
and certificate for completion
the third level of subscription is the
advanced level of subscription and the
fees for that level of subscription is
dollar 350 and the resources include are
online tutorials project examples cloud
pipelines coding sessions session
recordings live group sessions
one-on-one mentor support
and
you have an opportunity to
work on your research proposal and
present to the mentor for the evaluation
then certificate of completion and also
certificate of excellence
now
we are right now providing with a good
scholarship
those students who are interested or
those participants those who are
interested for a scholarship can fill
out the scholarship form i have shared
the link in the chat box and after
reviewing the form we can
get back to you
so uh is there any question regarding
the enrollment process
if yes so please uh put that query in
your chat box
also
uh for any query we are available at
marketing at the rate omixlogic.com
the link
the email id is in the chat box
and for indian contacts we specifically
have a contact number
that is
nine eight
seven six one three four
one two zero
so anyone
is having any kind of query can mail us
at marketing other at omixlogic.com and
can call us at nine eight seven six one
three four one two zero specifically for
indian contacts
now i would like to pass on
this stage to dr raghuv england
so as to continue with his visualization
process
thank you everyone
thank you very much
okay let's uh
so yeah it is good news because the
visualization is back on it is working
so let me show you how we can build a
demo pipeline and then access the output
file so that you can
get a sense of what these analysis can
give you and how these analysis can be
performed and what all can you infer
from these analysis so let's quickly go
to um
quickly our screen i'll share everything
[Music]
i think that is going to be helpful yes
i'll share everything
and okay
[Music]
thank you very much so we go to the
server t by one for platform and then
under genomics analysis uh we go to
mutation variant and parallel analysis
of mutation variant data and then
sorry we have built these demo pipeline
for students like you who are enrolled
in the program to access these outputs
and to access these
pipeline building
experience so that you can get a sense
of how to work with the platform and
what are the output files and what are
the biological implications that we can
get from the output file so let's click
the demo source scope to visualization
platform so this follows the analysis uh
we're not going to do mutation variant
parallel necessary mutation variant but
we are going to do um
we are considering um
let's see that if we are we have
sequenced a new strain of source co2 or
we have sequenced a sample of sars co2
isolated from a patient we encounter so
we want to map it on to the reference
genome and see what are the
different differences or variance that
our
particular sample contains or has
interest with respect to the reference
genome that we can map it on to a
different genome that we can identify so
in order to do that we obviously have to
start and then after clicking start the
pipeline is going to give you all
possible routes that you can navigate to
so the only route that we have right now
is using about i2 because the input is
is a list of fast queue sequences and
this is also here to simplify the for
users like you so that
you don't get confused with very many
different options that are available at
a different point so when you are going
to build your own pipeline and then by
inputting the relevant
input files in fastq format then you are
going to have options for pre-processing
mapping and
all the other options available to you
so you have to build the pipeline based
on how you have understood
the lessons that
the associated lessons in which we are
going to explain the logic behind ah
this nga sequencing analysis and uh how
to perform this in in the platform so
let's click
this mapping it's going to tell you what
is going to do
and some associated parameters that you
have
that you have to set most of the time
these parameters will remain in the
default
option and if not then you will have a
specific instructions on what to uh
what to enter at which place in their
associated lessons so we uh we now
visualize the mapped sequences or map
reads onto the genome using
visualization and then after this we
will end the pipeline
so if you end the pipeline now as i
mentioned you get uh access to
access to these files you can download
these files and visualize in your own
computer but that is going to take long
time because this is like
almost like 80
almost like 0.8 gb
these files so let's uh click
visualization here which is going to
take us to
the inbuilt j browse tool which will
help us visualize this
this analysis so we let it load
then quickly check if
if any specific uh
chat is there okay
are we quickly
still loading
so uh
first you are going to have not all of
these ticked on and yeah so we will have
our genome seek genes and then we'll
have reference sequences so that is
going to be populated here and then we
will have the
alignment coverage and snp is here
usually this is going to be only
alignments so you'll have a not like
this since i have used this it's going
to be like that so let's
if you see
something like this then
we have to load it again
okay it says we have too much data to
show let's zoom in so let's zoom in
okay now you can see
the reads that are
aligned to the reference sequence of the
reference sequence now you cannot see
because you have to zoom in let's
zoom in a little bit more
so that we can see the reference
sequences and there you go you can see
badly
yeah
so this is going to be your forward
sequence this is going to be your
complementary sequence you have all
three different um amino acid
translations based on the starting
quarter points and we don't want those
we will actually turn this off for now
uh show translation so that it simply it
simplifies our view so that is good so
what you see here is actually bar codes
actually because these are very closely
uh packed you cannot you can see uh like
a band so this is a uh
coverage uh of this this represents the
coverage of our sequencing
effort at this particular specific
position so you can obviously see some
at some portions we have some
differences or we have some minute
deviation so
for example this read the red ones which
is a forward
strand
has a
variant here with respect to the
original sequence there so we can
see whether
if you double click this if you click
this once then it's going to give you
uh
a window view of the
read the read that you actually clicked
and then that is going to give you the
quality score associated with this
particular position we can actually
check whether what is the quality score
of this one so i think this is not very
good quality how to identify this i
think
yeah that that is why it is not called
in and also it is only present in only
one of these reads and all the other
reads actually uh coincide or actually
agree with the um this particular
position so if you uh click this bar
this actually bar we have 446 reads
mapped onto this specific position out
of which 444
agree with the reference sequence which
is a
[Music]
t or
t in the forward sequence you can see
it's t in the forward strand and
only two of them are a mutated variant
to
a so this doesn't qualify as a
significantly uh identifiable variance
so that is why we do not have any other
marking uh in this particular position
because they are they occur only at two
of the two of our first q files or two
of our reads compared to the 400 500
different reads so that is almost
nothing so it's not statistically
significant so it is not called so when
you scan through the genome you will
find landmark areas like this so here
you will see that you have a
marker so if you click that
here you can see that there is a variant
in this specific position
and
this specific position has a very good
coverage just as it is depicted by this
particular
bar which goes from here and if you
scan anywhere in this
in this identified position which
qualifies this
this variant as a significantly
occurring variant you can see that the
reference is
cytosine and we do not have any cytosine
at all we have 442 of our reeds and
mutated or having a significant variant
to thiamine and two of them to guanine
so this this is how you can identify uh
specific variants and this is how you
can visualize specific variants this
will be extremely helpful
once you perform this statistical
validation of these variants and then we
can come back to the visualization to
identify in which portion of the gene or
or
specifically which portion of the genome
does this variant occur whether you have
yeah
and how does uh other fastq files agree
with that or not so this is how we can
do so you can actually zoom out to
navigate through this
space in a much quicker way and then
when you do that you can also appreciate
the
variations that or appreciate the
differences in the coverage that our
sequencing effort has actually produced
so these are the regions where you
cannot believe a lot because you you do
not have
very many coverage in these regions
but wherever you have bars really high
and that those places you can
believe them so
this is just a very uh very quick sample
of how you can visualize the uh mapping
of fastq files onto the reference genome
and
and of course you do not have to go
through okay
here we have identified one more of
these and this is really highly variant
did you see that so you have a lot of
variation this particular specific
position
and we have a deletion
mutation also you can see uh it's
yeah
so there is a deletion of one nucleotide
here also so uh that you can identify a
lot of uh
um variance with this so uh this is how
you will visualize um
the variance so
while you go through the program you
will also have
how we can perform this analysis and we
can uh visualize this and how you can
build a pipeline by yourself so that you
can perform a
sequencing analysis or build a pipeline
like this to visualize your data so if
you have any queries please let me know
i will take those questions
and
if not then i'll hand it over back to
sparsh
and thank you very much for your
participation
yes thank you
thank you so much
so yeah
so i would like to uh tell you one uh
all one thing uh those participants who
are interested in scholarships please
provide this with your email id here in
the chat box so we'll mail you out about
uh we'll mail you about the scholarships
and also please add marketing at the rit
omixlogic.com
in your mailing list because sometimes
spam gets triggered of bulk mailing so
do check
mails in your spam fold folder and
promotional tab
thank you also do uh if we have some
queries related to the session or the
enrollment process please feel free to
uh put your query in the chat box
so that we can answer those
thank you sara uh
thank you david for updating your email
id
so i am noting down the email ids
and we mail you out
in just a short file
do we have any queries regarding a
session
if yes so please feel free to drop the
question in the chat box
uh dr raghuvendran i think so we have a
question over here
uh so prashi is asking how do we select
cut off values for selecting the reads
uh okay
prachi uh if you can hear me yes uh i
got myself admitted okay this is done by
the fastq quality control uh algorithm
uh which is part of the traumatic
algorithm that you will select when you
are uh selecting your pipeline and then
you have we will have a visual visual uh
feedback of how these fastq files
[Music]
are the how the quality scores of these
fast q files vary at each and every
different positions and their
distribution across different pascal
files you can perform perform this fast
q quality control classes standalone
package also in the utilities and there
by identifying which portions of the of
your fastq files of your read files are
dipping below the uh
below the threshold which is usually
around
if you go to if you use the first qc
html output then it is given green red
and yellow so the top um
80 percentage or above below i mean
whatever scores that are above 80
percentage are considered as
excellent uh
read quality and what that comes from
yeah around 30 thank you very much
around 30 yeah so whatever goes down
below that will be
for your discretion to identify or to
trim it from the uh
read files so
you can run this analysis as a
standalone version and then decide um
i decide
trimming that you can perform so that
you can make an excellent uh ask you uh
files or retails yeah
in
some of the lines were purple and
usually correspond to
very low coverages are these various
sequences weren't that similar to others
i mean you will find there are there are
ways in which
some of these in the j browse
only those that are that qualify as a
significant variant they are given those
mutation landmarks so others are just
left like that and you can actually turn
off the other
other
ones these could be due to technical
error this could be due to uh low
quality of that of that in that specific
position so you can go through those
first key files to verify what is the
issue there
if we have uh
i have okay and then
sir j browser working like mega x i have
no experience with the mega x naveen
um
j browse and igv will have very similar
display but jbrowse obviously you can
work it as a you can use it as a
we use it as a tool to display or help
you visualize the heavy sam file on bam
files
yes for visualization only yes it is for
visualization
but this becomes extremely important
also and you will have other statistical
statistical tools to validate your
variants like uh
like different variant calling
algorithms that we will employ to
identify mutations that are significant
and statistically significant so you
don't have to visually go through each
one of them and then note down the
variance so this is for visualization
purpose where you can
relate to those
mutants that we have identified in the
sequence where they occur and how they
occur and in terms of
viral genome where you do not have large
a lot of genes and large number of
sequences then uh you can actually
go through this visualization and
identify how these relate to different
structural uh forms of their protein
that they encode and i think that will
answer some of the questions that you
have throughout and then we have a
we have a question regarding the
recording of this session i think uh
spurs can answer that
and when and how that will be made
accessible
yes
and any other queries related to
uh
to the session today
uh i think so a doctor agreement uh
prachi has a query her hand is raised
can you please answer sorry i did not
notice
i think prachi is not here i think yeah
that's okay so any other queries
so about the session recording uh yes uh
you will get a mail
about this uh insights of this session
surely uh by tomorrow itself
so any other queries regarding session
please uh okay thank you thank you for
letting us know
i think he has his uh
question
uh salaam alaikum
hello back yeah uh my name is bakara
ahmata uh
i'm bsd student in ukm in malaysia
my project about
covered 90
i use actually i use a biosensor laser
for detection chronovirus
on the service
therefore
the
the bioinformatic information
can i i get how uh extra action feature
such as spike and envelope diameter
sorry can i
can can you use
yeah
can i get uh extra action feature for
for uh
virals such as
spike length
and envelope diameter
yeah you can
i think
ah
because i use i mean uh image processing
with yeah the laser i get it yeah i
understand your query that's very
interesting i mean in a way uh uh dr
mukhidif is here i think he's not here
but in a way you can get spike length
from the protein itself from the 3d
structure of the protein
indirectly you can you can calculate the
um
you can calculate the
ellipsoidal radius of that particular
globular protein that will correspond to
this pipeline but
not in not in the way that you would uh
identify i mean in order to get the
envelope radius
you have to use some other data
you cannot use the sequencing data to
get envelope radius no i i don't think
it is going to be very related to
an envelope radius
if yeah because
in this and
and i find it really difficult to
extract the envelope radius information
from the
cold because because it doesn't even
annotated
yes yeah because this feature
protection by laser
very interesting
because i need
the laser as of land when i scan a scan
scanning any service cannot
cannot i have knowledge about this virus
or bacteria
but i use this feature to
to get
the laser
knowing this viruses by this feature
spike and the
outline outline shape viruses
this
i need i need to
use image processing to extraction this
feature
yeah i think i don't know maybe maybe uh
by laser method itself i think you can
get uh
get the features as you were uh actually
demo as you were actually explaining but
uh i don't know whether ngs technology
can address your query in this
particular regard i don't think it can
also do that
okay okay thank you
thank you thank you for the insights
thank you and any other queries
okay i don't see any and then thank you
very much for your participation one
more time and hope to see you all in the
program um
in the next session and in the program
thank you very much if uh nothing else
to add uh
then we can hand it over to spurs
if she has anything else to uh add to
this
uh no no it's uh everything is i think
so clear so and the maximum of the
doubts are also clear dr raghuvandaran
it was glad to have you all over here
and uh looking forward to meet you all
in the next session in the program
itself
so thank you
thank you we also look forward to seeing
you thank you
you